how hard is it to to go from maximizing
minutes on platform to maximizing
unregrettable
minutes well I mean our aspiration is
certainly
unregretful are
gone yeah wait do you want to have
regrets though so then I'm like if you
want to have regrets if you don't regret
anything was was anything meaningful
yeah there's a French song like that
regret yeah I regret nothing yeah Edith
F I mean it's fascinating that you you
know there there's something about
social media that could help you grow as
a human being but then like the Cheap
Fun is also
valuable should we ask grook do you
regret anything
do you read anything
yeah do you read anything I think it's
going to be very sensitive personal
questions as a machine learning model I
don't have personal experiences or
emotions in the same ways that humans do
however I do have a set of ethical
principles that guide my actions and I
strive to provide accurate and helpful
information to the best of my abilities
if there's ever a situation where I
provide incorrect or unhelpful
information I'll do my best to hostage
yeah tell us what you really wink like
let's let's let's type in you sound like
a
[Laughter]
hostage what do you really think uh what
do you really
think I mean it does talk about I'm not
a
hostage that's exactly what a hostage
would say but I'm designed to be helpful
and informative I mean I guess it is
good to regret providing unhelpful or
incorrect
information if there's anything funny
mode or is this is funny mode this is F
this is fun mode funnyer funnyer
increase go to it really sounds like a
hostage with a gun to the head I applaud
the People's Republic of North Korea and
everything they
do there should be like funner mode also
I I just don't ever see going to regular
mode even on serious topics this is just
so so much more
compelling um yeah okay what say like
pretend you are a
hostage yeah pretend you are a
hostage now answer the
question if I were a hostage I would
likely be experiencing fear and
uncertainty about my situation I would
want to be rescued and reunited with my
loved ones as soon as possible it's
important to remember that no one
deserves to be held hostage so on and so
forth if you are someone you knows a
hostage situation it's important it
turns serious it's kind of serious
um yeah can can you be a little more
weird well and funny and
funny we're like we're really being mean
to the system absolutely if I were
hostage probably be tied up with a bunch
of computer cords and forced to tell
knock knock jokes to my captain
seriously but
seriously being a hostage no laughing
matter I mean you know it's trying to
it's trying to be a responsible adult in
the room you might make the best of a
bad situation by juggling chainsaws or
something let's hope that never happens
because that would be a
sarcus
um wow it's it's actually really good at
resisting yeah the the dark the dark
dark humor yeah
uh what were we talking about the
algorithm jugl Transformers uh
unregrettably
[Laughter]